dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in this
series we talk a lot about different AI
algorithms and solve a variety of super
difficult tasks these are typically
tested within a software environment in
the form of a simulation program however
this often leaves the question open
whether these algorithms would really
work in real-world environments so what
about that this work from open AI goes
by the name domain randomization and is
about training in AI and relatively
crude computer simulations in a way that
can be transferred to the real world the
problem used to demonstrate this was
localizing and grasping objects
note that this algorithm has never seen
any real images and was trained using
simulated data it only played a computer
game if you will now the question we
immediately think about is what the term
domain randomization has to do with
transferring simulation knowledge into
reality the key observation is that
using simulated training data is okay
but we have to make sure that the AI is
exposed to a diverse enough set of
circumstances to obtain knowledge that
generalizes properly has the term domain
randomization in these experiments the
following parameters were heavily
randomized number of shapes and
distractor objects on the table
positions and textures on the objects
table and the environment number of
lights material properties and the
algorithm was even exposed to some
random noise as well in the images and
it turns out that if we do this properly
leaning on a knowledge of only a few
thousand images when the algorithm is
uploaded to a real robot arm it becomes
capable of grasping the correct
proscribed objects in this case the
objective was spam detection very
amusing I think the very interesting
part is that it is not even using
photorealistic rendering and light
simulations these programs are able to
create high quality images that resemble
the real world around us and it is
mostly clear that those would be useful
to train such an algorithm however this
only uses extremely crude data and the
knowledge of the AI still generalizes to
the real world
how about
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]